[Applaudissements]
je suis le roi du ciseau de la Barber
champiseau je suis le Barbier de
Belleville des petits poils jusqu'au
cheveux je fais vraiment ce que je
veux j'ai toujours été hanté par le
désir de chanter Manon Carmel au corn
ville alors avouez que c'est ralent
d'avoir la vocation sans l'UR
talent je n'ai pas de voie
j'essayie
quelquefois mais ça ne vient
pas pas douer pour
l'OP mes clients me comparent au fameux
rasur Figaro je ne suis que le Barbier
de
Belleville je peux vous passer un
shampoing mais vous faire un tour de
champoing
je suis je prends les paris le meilleur
de tout Paris pour tous les goûts dans
tous les
sty je fais un métier que j'adore mais
je voudrais
chanteror
adore je nai pas de voix jeessis quel
que sois mais ça je ne VI
pas pas doué pour
leage
c'est comme ça je ne suis l caros
Rossini je ne suis que le Barbier de
Belleville je n'aurais jamais été là le
partenaire de la
Gal alors de mon bistouri je taille les
favoris des bonnes gens de la
Grandville en rêvant que je suis à le
Garnier ou bien
[Musique]
à je n'ai pas de voix
je sais
quelquefois mais ça ne vient
[Musique]
pas
oh j'ai pas
[Musique]
doué